alors que ces derniers mois les membres
du gouvernement avaient davantage
l'aspect de père fouettard que de père
noël
les choses semblent changer en effet
olivier béland actuel ministre de la
santé a déclaré ce matin sur france info
que la menace d'un troisième confinement
n'était pas d'actualité est évidemment
possible qu'on ne soit jamais
reconstruit
alors que tout le monde s'attendait à un
durcissement des règles cette
déclaration a étonné un grand nombre de
téléspectateurs d'autant que le ministre
précise dans le même temps que les cas
de kovy n'ont pour l'instant pas diminué
de la situation est stable à un niveau
élevé encore une fois mais stable oui
les vers en alerte tout de même sur un
futur pas si serein si ça devait évoluer
et que vous échapper nous prendrions
alors les décisions qui sont nécessaires
pour sauver deux hôpitaux et sauver des
vies alors olivier ferrand at il raison
d'éloigner l'hypothèse d'un reconfirme
ans en attendant le virus n'a pas
disparu et la situation est loin d'être
sous contrôle
ce soir les docteurs jimmy mohamed et
martin blachier se feront faire
[Applaudissements]
on apprend que sérieux tu n'as pas ici
les médecins il est possible qu'on ne
soit jamais recongeler elle et moi je
vois là on va fermer leur gueule chérie
je vous le dis donc il est possible
qu'on soit jamais recombiner olivier
révérend at-il raison d'éloigner
l'hypothèse dans le confinement merci
d'être avec nous c'est une émission
sérieuse alors ça quand on n'est pas là
pour déconner vous avez des pancartes on
dit oui non si vous n'avez pas envie de
mettre des pancartes voulait foot ou
gimme more mais non tu aimerais qu'on
démarre pas abouti écoutez moi je suis
un peu pas de cadastre fait très
inquiètes ce genre d'annoncé vrai
vraiment mais vraiment parce que non pas
que j'ai envie qu'on soit confiné parce
qu'on va croire que finalement les
médecins veulent absolument d'un
confinement si ce que disent les jours
parfois ils disent ouais les médecins
ils sont alarmés estime qu on confine
parfois il ya même des gens qui qui vous
n'en veulent non mais c'est vrai
lesnumeriques mon départ alors de
mauvaises nouvelles et non mais c'est
chiant que vides on en a marre et puis
on est là on fait peur aux gens ça fait
un an qu'on vit avec house et tromper on
a dit beaucoup de bêtises et
certainement pendant dire à d'autres et
donc je peux comprendre que certains
nous en veulent mais quand on entend la
phrase de l'île et veyran alors est-ce
que c'est peut-être un peu d'arrogance
un peu de provocation parce que
j'aimerais dire aux gens que lorsqu on
confine on a une perspective de
déconfinement échos déconfinement va
regagner des libertés le problème c'est
que l'année sur un plateau il dit on est
stable dans l'augmentation je sais pas
moi mais quand je suis à découvert lors
si c'était le cas des cinq personnes
votre banquier quand vous avez moins
1000 euros et puis moins 1100 euros puis
moins 1200 et vous dis pas vous est
stable dans le découvert il voudrait que
je souhaite mais bon qui connaît bien
les injures dont il faut faire quelque
chose ce plateau ils semblent infinies
il ne va jamais s'arrêter ça veut dire
que la perspective de réouverture des
bars et des restaurants des salles de
sport du cinéma du spectacle de
retrouver un peu de vie les remontées
mécaniques d'aller en vacances eh bien
on va traîner ça pendant combien de
temps pendant trois quatre mois alors
que si on avait confiné peut-être un
moment un peu plus précoce on aurait pu
retrouver une vie normale
sauf que là on va peut-être se travaille
mal et ça jusqu'à au printemps à l'été
le temps que tout le monde soit vacciné
alors que l'absence de perspectives hier
où il ya des gens qui le voient comme un
motif d'espoir et c'est normal et
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes content de
moi j'aime bien la nouvelle stratégie du
gouvernement qui ne stratégie de
transparence et d'honnêteté quand ça va
pas ils le disent quand ça va ils le
disent et c'est bien ça fait du bien au
moral des français puis l'ont compris
le confinement c'était aussi une norme
morale et sociale moi ce que j'espère
juste qu'ils nous confine pas là pour
nourrir confiné en avril ce qui très
confiné je préfère être confiné en hiver
en février pense qu'à sa gueule
j'allais très beau bermuda voilà pas
envie de les gâcher
alors est ce important vous m'excuserez
que donne d'abord la parole au but mais
je sais que vous êtes très calés sur le
sujet a pris c'est important d'écouter
déjà une semaine révérence dépression
justement pour cor confine pourquoi
parce qu'il avait la peur du rail
anglais qui étaient j'étais devant ses
yeux aujourd'hui la situation s'est
laquelle ces 50% de varier anglais dans
les yvelines
c'est 40% de varier anglais en ile de
france as qu'à une reprise épidémique
non donc je pense que le xz cutif en
train de comprendre que c'est pas parce
qu'un variant anglais qui prend de la
place sur les autres souches virales que
nécessairement on va avoir une envolée
de l'épidémie juste avant de venir ici
j'étais au téléphone avec mes collègues
suisses à genève il aurait confiné le
variant anglais il a + 50% d'épidémie
ils ont aucune reprise une épidémie qui
descend donc je pense qu'on est en train
de se rendre compte que c'est pas parce
qu'un variant qui prend de la place sur
les autres variantes que ça veut dire
que l'épidémie va exploser et que si
l'épidémie elle a explosé au royaume uni
au portugal et en espagne parce qu'ils
ont rouvert les bars et les restos c'est
pas parce qu'il y avait un variant donc
je pense qu'on est en train de changer
la manière dont l'épidémie
olivier ferrand il est la bonne
stratégie mais bien sûr il est en train
de voir qu'il va pas y avoir cette
immense vague que tout le monde annonce
donc il sait qu'on va par confiner et le
sud est vers ans il comprend dans quel
sens va levant donc aujourd'hui se rend
compte que le président ne décidera pas
de re confiner le pays et du coup il
fait cette phrase alors lui les
contrôles gouvernement lui
et ils n'ont pas donné du show cap et
non le vrai problème c'est qu'on est
très perturbé par les avis de tous ces
médecins respectable de mort mais c'est
vrai que les indices ase et les autres
disaient le contraire comme par exemple
il ya un conseil scientifique qui
préconisaient les quatre semaines de
vacances pour les enfants
l'ajustement de nom pour fêter de faire
un confinement donc nous sommes perdus
c'est ça qui est pénible ça c'est sûr
vous êtes perdus plus longtemps vous la
question ces combats on parle de piquer
mais là le plateau ne suffit pas dire
qu'il faut confiné moi c'est ça ma
question c'est parce que là on attend la
prochaine vague on attend la prochaine
vague vous pensez pas qu'on est déjà
dans une valve ont justement un docteur
qui vous répondent derrière lui il est
tout noir gmt sont aussi nos priorités
ici les coloristes non mais quand on
était en octobre juste avant le premier
répond finement on voit bien qu'il avait
un énorme épique là on est dans une
situation similaire ça veut dire ça fait
quelques semaines qu'on a des confiné et
on voit qu'il ya un plateau il n'y a pas
de piquets ce que ça veut dire qu'on se
comporte mieux ça veut dire que on ne
sait pas combien de temps ça va durer et
puis les avis divergent aussi parce que
certains parlent de chiffres d'autres
parlent de malades et c'est peut-être ça
la nuance est mieux là on parle de 5000
cas de 5000 morts on sait pas trop plus
rien ne veut strictement rien dire
la seule chose c'est qu'il ya toujours
des gens qui meurent environ 500
personnes par jour qui marc ducos vide
d'une maladie pour laquelle encore une
fois on a un vaccin donc on a accepté ça
et puis on oublie que lorsqu'on laisse
circuler le virus on va avoir les
étudiants désormais 10 à 20% dès gens
qui vont avoir un colis de long c'est à
dire des symptômes persistants au delà
de six à huit semaines qui vont errer
dans la nature on ne sait absolument pas
à quoi c'est dur c'est pas comment les
aider on ne sait pas combien de temps ça
va durer
certains vont avoir des séquelles avec
de l'inflammation au niveau du coeur
pour l'appel des myocardite et puis j'ai
des amis radiologue qui font des
vacations de scanner et qui toute la
journée voit des malades
posco vide avec des scanners de fibrose
pulmonaire ça veut dire que laisser
circuler le virus pourrait aussi
s'exposer à un danger notamment celui
d'un mutant dans un hôpital français on
a identifié un variant français et on
dit on va l'envoyer la donne et asante
musique trance en disant il ya une
spécificité
on ne sait pas ce que ça va donner mais
invariants dans cet hôpital donc ça veut
dire qu'on bat s'exposer à autre chose
d'autant plus que l'on parle du variant
anglais c'est la menace immédiate mais
on a le variant sud africain c'est une
nouvelle menace les mac sans le sel sont
moins efficaces
alors les jeunes qui s'est dit mort
d'awk six ans il paraît que le vaccin là
le astra mécanicien il serait pas il
serait profitable contrôle mp ou pas
efficaces sur le variant
sud africain et c'est le machin qu'on
propose aux soignants les soignants qui
sont en première ligne
on leur avait dit le masque sert à rien
un dut souvenez vous l'avez dit le
masque ffp2 c'est pas la peine
et là on remet la même musique or ce
vaccin il est suffisant pour vous on a
qu'on n'a pas mis à vous proposer
à titre personnel je ne me ferai pas
vacciner avec le vaccin sera zeneca vu
que je suis exposé tous les jours je
travaille je vois des malades du corona
deuce et j'ai pas envie de le ramener
chez moi j'ai pas oublier les mateurs il
sans risque il est l'accent moderna et
phaser il est quand même moins efficace
mais il est plus efficace que l'astra
zeneca sur le variant sud africain va me
dire que si on veut offrir une
protection digne de ce nom aux soignants
on les applaudit beaucoup à 20 heures au
port faut leur donner le forez either
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va se contenter
encore une fois bien chamakh ça au
rabais pour les soignants veritas son
écart d'environ il voit pas de malades
ces différences l'aveyron et les gentils
d'accord je les aime beaucoup
s'il est compétent lui demande de faire
ton travail les médecins je dois être
resté confraternel mais voit pas de
malade les soignants tous les jours ils
sont charbon depuis un an
ils en ont marre et repas envie de non
seulement quoi pourquoi l'école lester
le faire le gros l'encéphale astrazeneca
parce qu'on en a besoin d'accès lula à
la cronulla propose et à l'instar des
mandats dans la stratégie d'urgence donc
sur le très court terme
et c'est là donc si on se fait vacciner
à ça sert à rien contre le variant de 6
alors on peut le proposer à la
population générale celle qui va pas
être exposés en permanence au virus
on peut imaginer à l'hôpital quand on a
des gens qui périodes d'urgence écrit le
quotidien vient tous les jours est
exposé au virus pour l'instant on dit
que 99% des souches vont être sensible
parce que c'est le virus classique ou le
variant anglais mais le sud africain on
finira par rencontrer tôt ou tard et
pourquoi nous les soignants on va
s'exposer un virus pour lequel on a un
vaccin mais qu'on ne vous donne pas
c'est pas acceptable et j'ai pas envie
lorsqu'on ne soient vaccinés avec
l'astra zeneca et dans six mois
ben j'ai rappelé vers le sud africain je
le ramène à mes parents à mes enfants ou
que je crée moi même des clusters et que
je contaminent des malades parce que
l'enjeu il est là donc ces vaccins
astrazeneca
pourquoi pas pour la population générale
mais pour les soignants en première
ligne c'est le refus opposé selon les
gens là juste pour rire des variants il
y en aura toujours
c'est à dire que s'il ya des variants
qui sortent et des variants qui ont été
résistants vaccin il y en a d'autres qui
vont sortir c'est à dire que ce virus on
va vivre avec ses parts amis combien de
temps mais tout le temps tout le temps
c'est comme le vin est vrai que j'ai des
trucs à faire
justement justement on vous passe quand
on est indéfiniment parce que ce virus
il va rester là donc il faut avoir une
stratégie de minimisation des risques il
faut pas passer notre temps à se re
confiné parce qu'il ya quelques morts de
ce virus qui sont non mais c'est une
réalité jeu derrière des banques
d'autres maladies à chaque fois qu'on
confirme le pays à peu près 30% de la
population qui fait des dépressions et
md suscite chez les plus jeunes
donc au bout d'un moment ce confinement
et fait plus de mal que de bien et ça ne
va pas faire disparaître le virus c'est
à dire qu'il va y avoir des et et on va
pas suffire de vacciner la population
française pour qu'on en soit sorti ça
c'est pas vrai ni le confinement ni la
vaccination ne sera définitivement que
c'est ce qui ce soir là il fallait juste
par rapport aux jeunes souvent dit oui
les jeunes semblent sont pas du tout
concerné il se trouve que moi je suis le
confronte état de près puisque dans le
lycée de mon mon fils ils ont fermé deux
classes suite à une vraiment une
contagion massive des jeunes et
aujourd'hui on sait que les jeunes sont
maintenant touchées par le vide comment
on peut être sûr et comme on peut
annoncer que rabadan combinant comme
maintenant on pense que les les jeunes
et les lycéens risque de ramener à la
maison là donc c'est des parents donc
c'est moi et endurance quand c'est moi
c'est aussi mes parents je pense que
s'il ya un peuple ou alors je ne
comprends rien mais comme les autres qui
khimki me kitimat d'appel
aujourd'hui alors que vous les joies du
rien ça non non avant au moins j'ai
effectivement j'étais j'avais
l'impression que les jeunes étaient
vraiment pas concernés aujourd'hui
excusez moi il ya plein de cas de jeunes
qui sont maintenant touchées par le
comité donc ça m'a posé un problème dans
pas très longtemps
c'est une question de communication on a
dit qu'on confinera quand on n'aura plus
le choix
là on peut encore se permettre puisque
les hôpitaux ne sont pas place à donc on
vous promet que pour l'instant ce n'est
pas nécessaire
tiens c'est vrai ça déborde pas mais en
mars si jamais l'épidémie reprend vous
dira mais regardez ma petite dame
malheureusement les services sont pleins
et donc on va accepter
ah bah oui finalement il faut confiné à
vous qu'on va confiné plus longtemps et
oui les jeunes participent à l'épidémie
la seule chose c'est qu'on les teste un
peu plus qu'avant on a évité de faire un
peu les ignorants en pensant qu'ils ne
tombent pas malades et qu'ils ont qu'une
simple rhinopharyngite mais
effectivement on aurait pu profiter la
proposition du conseil scientifique de
fermer un peu plus longtemps les écoles
là elles vont fermer deux semaines donc
mécaniquement il devrait y avoir un
plateau qui va ralentir ou être
stabilisé pas ses chaussures sacs et
mise un ami sur sa survie sur son ils
oublient une chose une chose qu'on a
oublié notamment lors de la deuxième
vague
on a été étonné de la vague de froid et
certains ont dit ah ben c'est tout vu
venir c'est cela la glace